JACQUELINE FULLER: Well, good
morning, everyone and welcome.
I'm Jacqueline Fuller
and I lead google.org,
which is Google's philanthropy.
And welcome to
today's panel, where
we're going to be talking to
some of the folks who are doing
the most innovative
work around the world,
using technology to take on
the world's biggest challenges.
Let me start by giving you
just a little bit of background
on google.org.
So across Google, we provide
about $100 million each year
to non-profits and schools and
universities around the world.
We also have our Googlers
volunteering more than about
100,000 hours and we give
about a billion dollars
worth of free products
to non-profits.
Two quick examples
of some of the things
we're working on-- one that
we launched here at I/O
is a global effort
to use technology
to help people living
with disabilities.
So around the world, there's
more than a billion people
who are living with
either a cognitive
or a physical disability.
And so we launched a
$20 million open call.
So if you have a technology-- an
idea for how to use technology
to help people with disability,
we'd love to hear from you.
And out in the sandbox, we have
some of our current partners
who are doing things like
3D printing of prosthetics
or haptic vests that can help
the deaf community potentially
hear through sensory input.
Another-- and if you want
to talk more about that,
Raquel Romano is here.
She's a Google [INAUDIBLE].
Happy to talk to
you more about that.
Raquel's raising her hand.
Another example of an
effort google.org's
involved in is we
want to see more women
and underrepresented
minorities in computer science.
So we've invested
more than $50 million
in partners who are helping
to make that happen.
And if you want to talk
to us more about that,
Ammaji Miller is here
and can talk to you.
All right.
So let's go to our panel now.
Thanks so much for joining
us here this morning.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to ask each of our panelists
to just briefly introduce
yourself and tell us the
problem that you're working on,
your big idea to take that
on, and how you're going
to know if you're successful.
And Jen-- if you could
start, Jen Pahlka,
just giving us also a sentence
or two about yourself, who you
are.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: OK.
Hi.
I'm Jennifer Pahlka.
I'm the founder and executive
director of Code for America.
I just-- well, it's not
that recent anymore,
but I've been saying
that recently, I
came back from a year
stint in the White House.
So I've had some
experience in government,
which was relevant to--
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Very relevant--
JENNIFER PAHLKA: The big
idea, the big problem
that we're trying to
solve at Code for America.
The way I like to
talk about it now
is that if government can't do
digital well, it can't govern.
And we've seen some
big examples of that
in the past year and a half,
but there are many, many more
examples that you don't see.
And we see them and we'll
talk about that, I think,
as the panel goes on.
And so our big
idea to fix that is
to bring practices,
products-- technology
products-- and people
to the equation that
have a fundamentally different
approach, an iterative,
data-driven, and user-centered
approach to solving problems
with technology.
So we've been doing that
for about five years now.
And what we think is if we can
continue to help government
do government in
the 21st century,
then the world will
look pretty different,
because not only will we have
government services that work,
but I think that is how
fundamentally we build trust
in this major institution that
we forget how much we really,
really do rely on and we
need it to work for us.
So I think getting
government to work
is how we build that trust back.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
You're setting
your metrics pretty high there.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: A little, yeah.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Pretty high bar.
All right, Nithya.
NITHYA RAMANATHAN: Hi,
I'm Nithya Ramanathan.
I'm the co-founder and
president of Nexleaf Analytics.
And what we noticed
early on was that there
is a lack of data in
the public sector.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Can I--
I just want to interrupt.
Also, start by just giving
them one sentence on who
you are, like what
your background is,
how you came to this, because I
think we've got a lot of folks
who are coming from different
backgrounds who might find that
interesting.
NITHYA RAMANATHAN: Yeah,
so I'm a technologist.
So I came from academia.
I was a faculty researcher
in computer science.
And actually, it
was there that we
started noticing that
there was this lack of data
in the public sector, plaguing
problems in the public sector,
particularly in global health.
And so take vaccines,
for example,
vaccines are a lifesaving
measure, especially when
administered to children.
And yet too often,
at an alarming rate,
vaccines are deteriorating
and going bad
because they are kept
too cold or too hot.
And so for many years,
many smart people
at the World Health
Organization,
governments,
ministries of health,
NGOs, have been
trying to address
the problems in
the refrigeration
to keep vaccines cold.
But nobody had any
data, so nobody really
knew what was going on,
what were the problems,
and what were the types
of problems and solutions.
And so when I left
academia to help start
Nexleaf Analytics, one of
the problems that we took on
was developing a sensor
platform that could first
of all, monitor how
vaccines are stored
and send out text messages
to nurses so that they could,
even the most remote areas
in Mozambique, Kenya,
and a number of countries
around the world,
could start taking
actions to fix problems.
But just as importantly
and where we really come in
is in thinking about the
analytics and the data that
can be then used across
thousands of sites in a country
to provide a government
with visibility
into their weakest links.
And so where we come
in is that we're
part of a small but now
growing group of technologists
and computer scientists who
are not just building a sensor
and selling it to a country,
but spending a lot of time
listening to nurses,
listening to governments,
listening to the WHO and UNICEF
to try to understand what
are the actual problems that
people are trying to solve,
and then get the
data to help answer
those specific questions so
that we're actually building
technologies that countries
are now wanting and demanding
and are now using.
And so what we see
success looking like
is now refrigerators
around the world
all instrumented with sensors
that can actually then issue
a call for help
when a vaccine is
about to go bad so that no child
has to receive a vaccine that
is spoiled or ineffective.
JACQUELINE FULLER: All right.
Thanks, Nithya.
Robert.
ROBERT LEE: Hi, I'm Robert
from Charity Water, director
of special programs there.
And the problem-- oh, my
background is pretty varied.
So by education, I have a
degree in computer science.
But then, I went into
management consulting,
then did a whole bunch of other
stuff, entrepreneurial stuff.
And then I worked for
the State Department
in the foreign service as a
foreign service specialist
working in tech
R&D, then got my MBA
and was coming back to
work in the Bay Area,
but then got introduced
to this nonprofit and got
pulled over to New York and
started working on this really
challenging project.
And the challenge was
basically to combat
the hurdles of keeping a
water point sustainable.
So all across Africa
and South Asia
and really around the world
where access to clean water
is difficult, there's
these wells that are built
and other forms and
they're breaking.
There's millions of them
broken around the world.
No one really knows exactly
how many of them are broken,
but it's a lot.
And there hasn't really
been a really good way
to keep them well-maintained
and in working order.
So we do this by doing
innovative approaches
to different
maintenance programs.
But in order for them to
make sense from a cost
logistical perspective is
we had to design and develop
a sensor to put in these wells.
And these sensors
can report back to us
how much water is flowing
and when it goes down
and there's no
flow going through.
So our purpose obviously
is to keep water
flowing all the time.
But we're hoping to
do even more than that
by setting a new precedence
in the sector that
no longer is it OK to just build
a well and not take care of it.
We have to commit to
giving clean water ongoing
beyond that initial moment.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Robert, you're
really trying to
establish a standard
not just for clean water, but
across the entire development
sector.
ROBERT LEE: Right, the
transparency, accountability,
and the standards.
JACQUELINE FULLER: And success?
ROBERT LEE: Success will come
when we get all the data back.
And I'll go into more
about the challenges
of what to do with all that
data and how to utilize that
and how it can continue to keep
providing a lot of benefits,
and where this year,
we're putting out
4,000 to 6,000 sensors
worldwide to start.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Great.
Rose.
ROSE BROOME: Hi, everyone.
My name is Rose Broome and I'm
the founder and CEO of HandUp.
My background is, like so
many people on this panel,
very mixed, but I
started in research,
in behavioral research.
And then, I ended up working
on the first Obama campaign
managing data, and
through that experience
was really inspired by
the power of technology
to create social change.
And so I decided to
leave the research path
and go into startups.
So I worked for an education
technology startup and then
a health startup before
I had an experience that
led me to found HandUp.
And that experience was I
was walking down the street
here in San Francisco and
I saw a woman sleeping
on the sidewalk.
It was really cold out.
And I asked myself why.
Why are people still sleeping
on the street at night?
And I told my friend about this.
My friend is an engineer
and we started brainstorming
and came up with the idea.
What if you could
donate directly
to a homeless person
using technology?
And we started working on that
and then we launched HandUp.
So you can donate directly
to specific homeless people
through our website
at handup.org.
Everyone can see homelessness
here on the streets,
but you may not know
that across the country,
3 and 1/2 million Americans
experience homelessness
each year and 46 million are
living below the poverty line.
So through donations but also
through human connection,
actually being able to
send messages to people
and hear back from them and
hear updates of their life,
we're trying to help
connect the community.
And success to us-- we're
one piece of the puzzle.
Poverty is obviously
a gigantic problem.
But success to us is
making sure that everyone
has a place to sleep
at night, food to eat,
and the opportunity to live
a healthy, meaningful life.
JACQUELINE FULLER: So let's dive
into one of our first topics
and that's going to be risk.
So in the tech industry, we all
know that taking informed risk
is part of success.
But as you get into
different cultures, academia
or the non-profit
sector or government,
this whole idea,
I think, is just
really scary and not as common.
So I just wanted to ask
about both the risks
that you're encountering
in projects.
And also a lot of you, as we
hear about your life plan,
took a lot of personal risk
in terms of making changes
along your career path.
So wondering, Nithya, if you
want to start us off and just
talk about how you handled risk.
NITHYA RAMANATHAN: Yeah.
So personally, there was a lot
of risk when I left academia.
I was in a job in
computer science
and as a researcher there and
leaving to start a startup
was kind of that initial risk.
But I think when
we first started,
we needed to create a
new model, because we
were a non-profit
technology startup.
And six years ago when we
started, not a lot of people
understood even
those words together.
And so we really--
JACQUELINE FULLER: Still don't.
[LAUGHTER]
NITHYA RAMANATHAN:
But we really had
to borrow from aspects of
NGOs, academia, and of course,
as well, being a
technology startup.
And as a lot of people that
have seen large-scale growth
in the private
sector for technology
know that success comes from
providing a technology that
makes people's
lives better, that
integrates into people's lives,
and that has a sustainable
business model.
Those are a lot of key elements.
And for us working exclusively
in developing countries,
that looks different.
And so for example, we have
had to take donor funding
to do our R&D so that we
had the time and place
to first spend years listening
to countries to really
understand, what are
the challenges that
are being faced in
order to get vaccines
to be delivered safely?
So spending years
listening to nurses,
listening to
district supervisors,
listening at the national
level, to WHO, to UNICEF,
to all of the
partners who all come
together to ensure that every
child on earth gets a vaccine.
And so not only did we have to
really understand the problems,
but then continuously
iterate-- of course,
we all talk about
that-- and then one
of the key elements
that we had to do
was go back and then
actually evaluate the impact.
And so for example, in
randomized controlled trials
in one of the poorest
health systems in the world,
in Mozambique, we showed
a 10x reduction in damages
to vaccines.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Wow.
NITHYA RAMANATHAN:
And that was critical.
That's really changed
the conversation.
JACQUELINE FULLER: And that's
saving both lives and money.
NITHYA RAMANATHAN: That's right.
That's right and that's totally
changing the conversation
at all levels of
the health system.
And actually, you
bring up a good point,
because at the nurse level,
they care about saving lives.
Of course, everybody
cares about saving lives,
but at the nurse level, that
really resonates with them.
And then at the national
level, at higher levels,
they care about
saving lives but money
has to be part of the equation.
It's how they're
making decisions.
And so absolutely,
these types of results--
JACQUELINE FULLER: Probably
helps with the adoption,
though, if you can say,
this is going to actually--
these systems, these
improvements could actually
pay for themselves.
NITHYA RAMANATHAN: That's right.
Of That's right
and it's completely
changed the conversation.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Tends to
open up a few more doors.
NITHYA RAMANATHAN: That's right.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Rose, how about you
on the subject of risk?
ROSE BROOME: Yeah,
risk-- any time
that you're trying to tackle
a big problem out there that
hasn't been solve-- we
don't know how to do it--
you have to take risks.
There is no clear path.
So risk is a very
important ingredient
in innovation across all
different innovation sectors.
Personally, a big risk
for me and my co-founder
was the moment where we
realized our side project was
getting a lot of traction.
And we had non-profits
who wanted it,
the homeless community
was excited about it,
and we were invited
into an incubator.
And we had this kind of moment
that every innovator faces
where it's like, OK, am I going
to take this leap of faith
and make this my life and
pour everything into this?
And we decided,
yes, even though we
didn't know how we were
going to pay our rent here
in San Francisco and how
it was going to work.
But we're so glad we did.
Another risk that I wanted
to share with you guys.
Along this topic of non-profit
technology organizations
and how many people
haven't heard of that,
well we've tried a
different approach here.
And so I don't know how
many legal buffs there
are in the room, but we
actually incorporated HandUp
as a new kind of legal entity
called a "public benefit
corporation."
That is a for-profit
that also has
a social mission embedded into
the foundation of the company.
And this was a risk for us,
because it's something new.
And for us, it gave us the
best of both worlds, to give us
the freedom to
innovate and the power
to innovate with the
for-profit model,
but also ensuring that
our values were embedded
permanently into the company.
But if you're doing
something new,
you have to take risks
and that's very important.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Well, if there's
anything that scares people
more than taking risk,
it's probably failure and
the possibility of failure.
Now, again, in
the tech industry,
that's something we're
much more comfortable with.
In fact, when I did my
last review with our CFO
at Google about our google.org
portfolio, his feedback to me
was, because I went
in saying, and we're
expecting across our portfolio
to have about a 10% failure
rate.
And he said, you need
to increase that,
because if you're not
failing more often,
then you're not really
funding innovation.
And philanthropy needs
to be risk capital.
And we need to be
really-- we're Google
so we can take those risks.
We understand that.
So go ahead and fund the
things that essentially
might have some more risk.
But let's look at
this topic of failure.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Why me?
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Jen notices that I
look to my friend
on my left and say,
is there anyone who
might want to talk
about the subject of failure?
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
Well, let's see,
maybe because I was in the
White House doing heathcare.gov,
maybe because we talk
about the need to fail.
And I think that one of the
things that I firmly believe is
that the comfort level with
experimentation, which imply--
you cannot experiment
and not fail.
Otherwise, you
didn't experiment.
You just did something
you knew would work.
That comfort level
with failure is
why it's so
important that people
from this community-- what
my old boss, Todd Park,
used to call "metaphysical
Silicon Valley."
You may live
anywhere, but you're
part of a community
that's comfortable
with it-- must come
to bring their skills
and your mindset to bear on
the problems that all of us
are trying to solve.
So government is sort of
famously failure-adverse.
And strangely, that
aversion results in,
at least at the federal level--
and this is just one study.
They think that 94% of
federal IT projects fail.
And it's interesting--
JACQUELINE FULLER: Is that 94?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: 94.
And it's interesting
the definition of it.
So you can say, well,
it never gets delivered,
gets delivered very, very
late or significantly late
or significantly overbudget.
So you could say,
OK, some of those
are just late or overbudget
and lots of things are.
But overbudget has a
different implication
or a different sort of scale at
the federal level than we do.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Way more zeroes?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Yeah.
So healthcare.gov--
before October 1,
they sort of pegged it
at about $600 million.
But it was really
more than that.
There was this piece of
the California court system
here for years that was
famous for spending $2 billion
to do what I think was trying to
basically replicate Google Docs
and then was scratched.
And so in the interest
of reducing failures,
we end up with a very,
very high failure rate.
And the line that explains
that to me the most is
what Clay Shirky said after
the failure of healthcare.gov
after he and I'd spent some
time talking about what we think
went wrong.
And he said, "The
waterfall method
amounts to a pledge
by all parties not
to learn anything
while doing the work."
And it's this extremely
front-loaded planning process.
I'm a fan of planning, but
you can take it too far.
We really find that what we
bring to the local governments
that we work with,
it's not just hey,
you need to be on
a different stack.
Hey, you need to do things
in a more lightweight way.
But we are going to show you
that we are comfortable trying
some things that don't work.
So in the realm of folks who
need assistance in our lives--
we worked with the
City of San Francisco
a couple years ago on a
problem with their food stamps,
so supplemental nutrition
assistance benefits,
food stamps, EBT cards.
You can sign up
for this program,
but it's very,
very likely you'll
get kicked right off of it.
The churn in the program
is very, very high
because of all the very
crazy administrative things
that have to happen for
you to stay on the program.
And they wanted us to
look at tech solutions
for solving that problem.
Really, it's a communications
problem, not a tech problem.
And the first things that
they did to solve this problem
were to create websites
and get information
to people at the same time.
And they tried about
four different things
that just didn't work.
The good thing is-- and this
is critical to failure--
is that they knew
that they didn't work.
And I think we have all
experienced this culture where
it's great that
you haven't failed,
because there's no data to show
whether you've failed or not.
But if you have that
data and you say,
now, I'm going to move on
to the next thing, that
gives you the power to iterate.
You have to have
something to iterate on.
Over time, that team
found out that they
could collect phone numbers from
the recipients, text message
these folks when they were
about to fall off the rolls,
and then get them to call the
office, which I know sounds
like the least sexy tech
project in the universe.
JACQUELINE FULLER: But it works.
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
It works and if you
want to get a sense
of the kind of work
that the Fellows are doing,
because they're continuing
to iterate on this
problem now two
and three years later,
I guarantee you,
you will be amazed at the
kind of work that they do.
The technology isn't
as hard, but the work
is really, really
fascinating, because they
know every day that they're
helping people go home
from the grocery
store with groceries
and feed hungry families.
And that is really,
really powerful.
JACQUELINE FULLER: All right.
So Robert, I know we've had
many, many conversations
about--
ROBERT LEE: Oh, failure,
too many, too many.
Yeah, I think-- so I'll give an
example of one of the failures
that we went through.
So we tested in the lab.
We coded it.
We built the hardware.
We're like, OK, this seems good.
Everything seems working.
Let's take it out
into the field.
We take it out to Ethiopia
and install 30 or 40 or so
and none of them
are communicating.
Or actually, I think only
one of them communicated,
one out of 30.
And we're like, wait,
what's going on?
So we looked back
at our firmware.
We looked back at everything
and we're like, what's going on?
Everything seems to be working.
And we find out
that it's actually
a problem with the
Ethiopian telecom network
and how they've configured
their backbone system.
So then, it led to
these conference calls
with our firmware guys in San
Francisco, me in New York,
Ethio Telecom, their
background network
in Italy with Italia
Sparkle, and our GSM chip
supplier in Hong Kong.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Those
are fun to schedule.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT LEE: Yeah, I think
it was 3:00 AM for me.
So we're doing these calls
and we just can't get it done.
So finally, it's like, OK.
So we have the Hong Kong telecom
expert fly out to Ethiopia.
We had to work with the politics
of the Ethiopian government,
because it's a
state-owned enterprise
to get them permissions
to get on to their system.
It gets on their system,
starts reconfiguring it,
gets our sensor transmitting.
And then, while he's
there, they're like,
oh, well, we also have
all these other bugs.
Can you fix these, too?
So he starts fixing those
bugs and all of a sudden,
I'm getting text messages
for the first time
on my AT&T phone in Ethiopia.
I'm like, yeah!
But it's hard because you don't
expect some of these problems
that you have.
And then, some things
seem out of your control
but you just kind of
have to go for it.
And so that's been--
communication in Ethiopia
is difficult, let
alone most of Africa,
where we want to
work in rural areas.
So now, we know like,
OK, we need to get ahead.
So we got right on Malawi.
We got on Uganda, Kenya,
Liberia, to make sure,
because with Ethiopia, the
contracts were all in place
and they actually had a whole
list of roaming M2M data
contracts in place,
but none of them
worked for the same reasons.
But we were the only ones that
actually had devices out there
for the first time, so
no one said anything.
And so we got this fixed.
We started moving forward.
I actually just went
to Ethiopia last week
to put out another-- we have
100 more sensors that we
are configuring to test the
next iteration of the firmware.
So then, I do that and
then again, one out of 30
is transmitting.
So I'm like, wait,
what's going on?
And I talk to Ethio
Telecom and find out
that they just upgraded
all their hardware
to get ready for 4G.
And then, they put on
the old configuration
before we fixed it, so now
I have to get the Hong Kong
guy to fly back out there--
JACQUELINE FULLER: You've got
to make the call again, too--
ROBERT LEE: And reconfigure
their system one more time.
Yeah, and that's
just one example
of the many ways,
the many hurdles,
the unexpected hurdles.
And I always tell
people-- and I'm
sure there's a lot of product
managers here and developers.
And I always say,
well, you spend
10% of your time preparing for
90% of what's going to happen,
likely case.
And then, it's 90% of your
time planning for all the
10% of things that
can go wrong, right?
But you have to, because
you have to make this work.
It has to be near
perfect, especially
in this kind of environment.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Well, this
is offering kind of a glimpse.
Sometimes, I get from
people like, oh, yeah,
I'm thinking about-- I'd like to
use my tech background to help
the world to do better.
But I'll do that when I'm
ready for retirement or I'm
slowing down or I
want something easier.
And there's, I think, sometimes
this sort of subtle notion
that, oh, because you're
helping people or doing good,
it'll not be as challenging
as some of the products
that they're working on.
So maybe if you guys
are willing to share,
what's the most
challenging thing
that you're coming across?
Rose, do you have?
ROSE BROOME: Yeah, I would
say so many technologists want
to work on very hard
technical challenges.
And when you think about
it, the biggest problems
that we face as a civilization
are poverty, energy,
environment, governance.
And if you can apply
that same mindset
to solving some of the
world's largest challenges,
you can have a very
fulfilling career.
And we're just at the
beginning of really seeing
technology, whatever phrase
you like, disrupt, augment,
support these industries.
And the water is very warm
and I encourage all of you
to jump in and join in.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Come on,
the water's warm, she says.
All right.
Nithya, do you have maybe a
specific challenge you want?
NITHYA RAMANATHAN: Yeah, sure.
So one of the
challenges that we face
is being able to rapidly iterate
and troubleshoot remotely.
So a little bit of what
Robert's talking about, but also
kind of-- take refrigerators.
These things are designed
with lots of money in the R&D.
They're tested in
very high-tech labs.
They get to remote
environments, lack of power,
lack of a lot of
other resources,
and they fail immediately.
So similarly with
remote sensors,
it's sort of this issue
of being able to test
as much as we can but
then be able to remotely
diagnose and
troubleshoot, as well.
And so trying to kind of
figure out that balance
and set up the environments
that we're still
able to kind of test as much as
we can rigorously in the lab,
but then also be able
to put in the components
that we can remotely
sufficiently instrument
our systems that we can remotely
troubleshoot and diagnose.
And then, I think finally
just dealing with the data.
We're going to be getting
data from tens of thousands
of sites in the next year or so.
And so just kind of thinking
about not necessarily
the actual volume of data--
not a lot of data, especially
being at Google-- but
just really thinking
about meaningful analytics.
What is really going to drive
change action in government
so that ultimately, we
can save more vaccines,
get more vaccines to kids?
One of those ongoing,
interesting challenges for us.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Can I speak
to the challenge thing?
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah, please.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Just you
mentioned this perception
that doing good
sometimes is like,
oh, maybe a little bit of
an easier job than say,
serving the millions and
millions of people that
would go to Google every day.
Just two quick
stories about that--
when we did our first Code
for America Fellowship
back in 2011, we had people come
from the tech industry, work
with city governments
for a year,
and we hoped that
afterward, they would all,
much like Teach
for America does,
would graduate into working
in government technology.
And we had 19 Fellows that year.
And at the end of the
year, we were going, OK, so
who's going to take a job?
And they pretty much all said,
we're so exhausted from this.
JACQUELINE FULLER: I'm
going back to my free lunch.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Yeah.
Well, the best was
Scott Silverman,
who had been at Apple.
And he ended up,
he said, I am going
to go back and
work at government.
I just need to relax
for a year at a startup.
I'm going to Airbnb.
This was 2011.
And the other story--
negative sells, I think,
work here, right?
It is incredibly hard work.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
This crowd looks to me
like a negative sell crowd.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: It is
incredibly hard work.
And the other story I would
tell is Googler Mikey Dickerson
came to the White
House when our--
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Our hero, Mikey--
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
Yes, go, Mikey-- and
was truly instrumental
in saving healthcare.gov
and worked-- we
added up his hours.
At one point, I think he had
worked 100 days straight,
20 hours a day.
So that's pretty intense.
But when he was very kindly
asking other Google SREs
to come help spell
other folks, since we're
building this team
that did really
do this amazing work
of getting the site
to get through that first
open enrollment period,
he would tell the
SREs that you will
learn more in a day
on healthcare.gov
than you will in a year,
because more things go wrong.
And I think that was a very
effective recruiting technique.
JACQUELINE FULLER: There you go.
All right.
Well, why don't we switch
gears and talk about advice
and lessons, all right?
So we have a crowd of
folks, a self-selected crowd
here and probably 50,000
or more on the live stream.
And these are folks who were
attracted to this notion of,
how do we use tech
to take on and solve
some of these big problems?
So more generally,
lessons you've
learned-- what do you wish
you could've told yourself
five years ago before this all
started or in the early days?
Or advice that you might have
for folks who are interested.
Just open it.
ROSE BROOME: Sure.
I can open up for this.
And the advice I
give to people who
want to become social
entrepreneurs is the same as I
give to any entrepreneur,
is think big but start
small, very, very small,
smaller than you would even
think at first.
And that's one of the
biggest challenges
that any early-stage
entrepreneur will face
is keeping your
scope under control
and staying very focused.
And I was saying
earlier about how many
incredible opportunities there
are in the social tech space.
I'll add to it, you don't
have to leave your company
to join in.
Every city has Tech
for Good meet-ups
that you can join and
become part of the community
and contribute in small ways.
And if your community
doesn't have one,
that's a perfect opportunity
to join in and start your own
and start bringing the social
entrepreneurial community
and the tech
communities together.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Robert?
ROBERT LEE: Yeah.
So I feel like I've
worked a broad spectrum
of private government,
like non-profit.
And I've been in non-profit
for two years now.
And the thing that
really bothers me--
it's kind of related
to what we were just
talking about in the
challenges is that when
people are like, oh, that's
really good, for a non-profit.
I'm like, why add
that disclaimer?
Why can't it just be good?
Why can't it be great?
And it is this
underlying thing of like,
oh, there's a lower
level of effort
or the standards are lower.
But actually, the
challenges are a lot harder.
And I'd love to say
the reason I came
to Charity Water-- of
course, it was a part of it,
but the biggest reason
was because there's
this altruistic motive.
I want to help the world.
Sure, that's part of it, right?
But that's not the main reason.
The main reason is because I saw
how big of a challenge it was
and I love taking on challenges.
Even in my other jobs, I used
to do turnaround strategies.
And I would ask them,
give me your worst group,
the one that's failing
the most, and let
me try to turn it around.
And I just jumped
doing turnarounds
and this was kind
of the same thing.
It's like, OK, there's
this challenge that's
been around for three decades.
Let's figure it out.
And an example is, how
many people are satisfied
with their cell phone battery?
Of course, we're not talking
about the Nexus, right?
JACQUELINE FULLER:
No, we are not.
No.
ROBERT LEE: But other
cellphones out there
and how do you feel about after
a year or two years, right?
And when it does drain, every
day, when you charge it,
you just walk a few feet and
plug it into the wall, right?
Well, imagine a world where
you have to put out a device
and the closest electrical
power source is a two-day hike
to the local market.
And there's no
local market where
you can even on the phones where
you can replace the battery
or you can just buy a new
battery and plug it in.
So we're building this sensor
that has to be out there
and last for 10 years,
because if we have
to go out and constantly replace
batteries for the sensor,
it kind of defeats the
purpose of saving money
by not having to go out
there to check on the well.
And so when we
built the sensors,
we had to look through
all these batteries
and figure out which one
works the best in that kind
of hot, humid environment.
We had to figure out-- we
implemented some AI techniques
and learning algorithms
so that the sensor can
be smarter and
only transmit when
it needs to at the most critical
moments and otherwise just
send us periodic things.
So it actually learns
its own behavior
of the well of what's normal
and looks at deviations.
And when we look at how to
approach all these things,
I'm not talking to people
that have never done it.
No, I'm talking to CTOs
of the major fitness-ware,
because they're thinking
of low-energy harvesting.
They're thinking of
how can we optimize
the power of management?
And when we build these
products, it's not just-- sure,
we start out in
the garage maybe,
but we're putting it
through everything.
We're manufacturing in China.
We're putting it through UV
chamber tests, heat chamber
tests.
We're shooting steel balls at
it to measure the durability.
We put it underwater.
We put it in humidity chambers.
There's no reason why we can't
build products that are just
as good, if not better, than
products built for the consumer
market in America.
And so my challenge, too, is
this attitude of even when we
do get people from the
private sector to help,
is they think it's
like, OK, I'll
just do this an hour
before I go to sleep.
this room is filled with some--
JACQUELINE FULLER: It's
going to take the best of who
you are, not your scraps.
ROBERT LEE: Right.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah.
ROBERT LEE: And I
got to the point
where we're Charity Water.
We have a good
brand in non-profit,
so we get offers for
discounts all the time.
I got to the point
when I was like,
I don't want you to
discount, because you give me
a 10% discount, then
what do I get, right?
I want to pay full price.
In fact, I want to pay
more than full price.
I want to pay top-market dollar
because I want your best.
And so when you
guys get involved--
you guys are the top talent--
really take it seriously.
It is a real challenge and
there's so many benefits.
Then, there is that
altruistic benefit
that you're getting
and not only that,
but again, if you like
facing challenges, which--
JACQUELINE FULLER: If
you like challenges,
do we have challenges for you?
NITHYA RAMANATHAN: I want
to jump in really quick,
actually, which is just that,
what if the killer apps are
actually in the public sector,
in these problems that we're
trying to solve, and
actually products
were designed-- rather
than designing products
in a first-world environment and
then trying to move them over,
what if it turns out that
actually in the developing
countries, that's where
the killer apps are
and then we bring
those solutions?
JACQUELINE FULLER: Well,
don't we all want this sensor
that Robert has
in a ball-bearing
chamber with the
humidity and-- if it
works in Eritrea
for six months, it's
going to be great
on my wrist, right?
No, that's a good point.
So as we're wrapping up any
last thoughts, Nithya and Jen
about advice that
you would give?
NITHYA RAMANATHAN:
I think I would just
go back to what I
said, really thinking
about how actually the
problems that we're
trying to solve in
Mozambique, in Kenya,
in Ethiopia around keeping
vaccines cold-- actually,
it turns out those problems
exist here, as well,
but aren't necessarily
maybe thought about.
But as we design
solutions in Mozambique,
we're actually finding
that partners in the US
are saying, hey, wait.
We want that.
Actually, our vaccines
are going bad here.
Our fridges are failing here.
And so we're working
with Planned Parenthood
and other partners and starting
to explore how we can actually
start scaling up.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
So they're saying,
hey, that thing you got
working in Mozambique,
bring it out here.
We need it in Brooklyn.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: I
see that all the time.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Advice, Jen?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: I
would take the question
as, what advice if you
really want to have impact?
And I'm going to make a
particular pitch there
around impact.
Think about any cause
that you care about.
It could be animal rights.
It could be feeding
the homeless.
I guarantee you the
government spends
100x what charitable
organizations are spending.
I'm not saying that
they're having 100x impact.
I think Rose's
work, for instance,
is having a huge impact
with very little investment.
But what if that enormous
investment that's
coming out of government
was spent better
and how could you impact that?
The numbers on-- the
size of government
is it's 15%, 20%
percent of our GDP.
There's more people
working in government
than in the entire companies
of the Dow-Jones combined.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Let
me just check the room.
Raise your hand if you've
ever worked for any government
around the world.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Awesome.
JACQUELINE FULLER: So
that was what, 10%, 8%?
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Yeah.
And I think that it's a
small amount considering
what a big portion
of our economy
it is and what a big portion--
JACQUELINE FULLER: Considering
that what governments
need most is probably
the skill set that's
represented in this room
and on the live stream.
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
And I think what's
changed, if some of you--
that was a couple of years ago
for you, even five
or 10 years ago-- it
used to be pretty different.
I think we used to have
this notion in government
that digital is
something you buy.
And we're trying
to teach government
it's something you do.
It's actually how we govern.
And so I think the
big shift has been--
and I think healthcare.gov
will always mark that.
I think we'll look
back at it as it's now
a time when digital people have
a seat at the strategic table.
They're able to say,
no, no, you can't just
consult me later and tell me
that we bought this thing.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Go
implement this thing
when the entire strategy
blueprint is off.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: Exactly.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Yeah,
we need tech at the table.
JENNIFER PAHLKA: You have to
be there from the beginning
and you have to be
in charge-- actually,
there has to be digital
competence within government,
not just in the
contracting ecosystem.
JACQUELINE FULLER: All right.
So we've got to wrap but I
would love for each of you,
for just 20 seconds
each, I think
you have a lot of
motivated people here
who might be wondering.
What's next?
How can I help you
in what you're doing?
So 20 seconds from each of you.
How can people help?
What's the next step?
ROSE BROOME: I'd
say, of course--
JACQUELINE FULLER: Go ahead.
Go ahead.
ROSE BROOME: I'd say go
to handup.org and help
a homeless person
in your community.
JACQUELINE FULLER: Handup.org
ROSE BROOME: And
of course, we're
hiring product designers,
engineers, project managers,
as are all these companies and
all of google.org's portfolio
companies.
So check it out if you're
looking for your next move.
ROBERT LEE: Yeah,
I would say contact
me, as well,
robert@charitywater.org,
pretty simple.
And with this product,
it's not only this project
that we're doing here.
But I actually have been-- and
as I speak in other places,
I've been pinged by
a lot of other people
that want to build tech for
non-profits and social impact.
And there's a lot
of different things
out there, a lot of different
ways to get involved.
It's pretty endless,
whether it's
hardware, software,
integration, whatever it may be.
So if you're interested
in getting more involved--
JACQUELINE FULLER: Brave
man, gave his email
to 50,000 people.
Nithya?
NITHYA RAMANATHAN: Same for us.
We're always hiring,
always looking
for really strong
technological talent,
and also, just hoping that
people who want to get
involved, whether it's with
Nexleaf or with others,
is really spending
time to understand
what are the problems and
how do we connect technology
to impact?
Ultimately, it's not
actually about the technology
but how we're actually
getting to that impact.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
Last word, Jen.
JENNIFER PAHLKA:
OK, so we want to be
able to show you that you can
have an impact on government.
If you have an hour, you can
use our Civic Tech Issue Finder
and just code on something
that needs coding
and that's at
codeforamerica.org/helpout.
If you want to come
once a week, there's
probably a brigade in your
city if you don't live here.
And that's at
codeforamerica.org/brigade.
So that's your citizen volunteer
groups that help City Hall.
If you've got a
year, we're currently
recruiting for our
2016 class of Code
for America Fellows, the
toughest job you'll ever love.
You'll get addicted, I promise,
and that's at /Fellows.
And if you're interested maybe
in actually looking at a job
in local, state, or
federal government,
codeforamerica.org/talent.
That Let us know that.
There's a bunch of really
interesting open positions,
particularly at the USDS in 18F
that would give you a chance
to be near Mikey Dickerson.
He's such a hero.
JACQUELINE FULLER:
All right, everyone.
Well, join me in thanking
our panelists for the work
that they're doing and
our conversation today.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, you guys.
All right, thanks, everyone.